Tenemos la ecuación, 7 menos 10 sobre "x"
igual a 2 más 15 sobre "x".
Esta no es una ecuación de las que estás
acostumbrado a resolver, pero te doy un momento
para que consideres si la podrías resolver solo.
Veremos que al hacer una multiplicación a
ambos lados, la podemos simplificar y llevarla
a una forma de las que estás acostumbrado a hacer.
Lo que probablemente te está molestando...
a mí sí me está molestando...
son estas "x" que tenemos aquí como denominadores,
¿cómo manejamos eso?
Como tenemos una "x" en el denominador, lo
que se ocurre es multiplicar por "x",
pero no podemos multiplicar tan solo un término
por "x", tenemos que multiplicar por "x" todo
el lado izquierdo, así es que multiplicamos
este lado por "x", pero no podemos multiplicar
tan solo un lado por "x", tenemos que multiplicar
el lado derecho también por "x".
¿Y qué nos resulta?
Bien, distribuimos la "x" del lado izquierdo,
aquí tenemos "7x" y "x" por -10 sobre "x",
es simplemente -10...
-10, así es que el lado izquierdo nos queda,
"7x" menos 10 y esto es igual a, de nueva
cuenta distribuimos la "x", "x" por 2,
es igual a "2x" y luego "x" por 15 entre "x",
"x" por 15 entre "x" cuando tienes "x" por
algo entre algo te va a dar ese algo, así
se que en este caso esto es 15.
Y ya la hemos simplificado como una ecuación
lineal, donde tenemos la variable a ambos
lados de la igualdad, simplemente tenemos
que aplicar las técnicas que ya conocemos,
vamos a llevar entonces las "x" del lado izquierdo
y para eso lo que se me ocurre aquí es eliminar
este "2x" restando "-2x", pero te recuerdo
que no puedes hacer algo de un solo lado porque
perdería la igualdad, hay que hacerlo a ambos
lados de la ecuación, así es que "-2x",
también lo tenemos que restar del lado izquierdo.
¿Y esto qué nos da?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda, voy a hacerlo
nuevamente en rosa, nos queda "7x" menos "2x"
esto es igual a "5x" menos 10 y del lado derecho
tenemos "2x" y "-2x" se cancelan, era lo que
queríamos y solo nos queda 15.
Ahora, podemos eliminar este 10 sumando 10,
prefiero el verde cuando hago cosas a ambos
lados, así es que sumamos 10 del lado izquierdo
y sumamos 10 del lado derecho.
¿Y qué nos resulta entonces?
"5x" -10 más 10 se cancelan y del lado derecho
queda, 15 más 10 es igual a 25.
Y ahora, para despejar esta "x" dividimos
entre 5 ambos lados y me queda, del lado izquierdo
me queda "x", del lado derecho me queda 5,
la solución es "x" igual a 5.
Verifiquemos que la solución es correcta,
vayamos a la ecuación original.
Tenemos 7 menos 10 sobre 5, ya estoy sustituyendo
el valor de "x" igual a 5 en la ecuación,
esto es igual a 2 más 15 sobre 5 y así del
lado izquierdo es 7 menos 10 sobre 5 es 2,
nos queda 7 menos 2 y del lado derecho tenemos
2 más 15 sobre 5, que es igual a 3, queda 2 más 3.
Del lado izquierdo es 7 menos 2 que es igual
a 5, 2 más 3 es igual a 5, 5 es igual a 5,
así es que nuestra solución es correcta,
hemos terminado.